okay hello everyone welcome to another
orphan language design review session
part of our language completeness and
consistency series
and we have a few topics here i'm
surprised we don't have more topics
actually but uh you know
that's that's
okay
let's talk about this topic what's that
yes i was gonna say you sent an email
with that basically being the entirety
of the content of the email so
okay all right here's what i had in mind
you know i've got a typical let's let's
find a typical kind of
uh let me find one
um
okay take a random
thing i've written find a random
yeah okay so gosh why isn't that too
okay here we go
there's
a
okay
this is a table as you can see
okay
yep it's got certain content here i mean
i don't know let's let's pull out that
content right let me just
you know make that
foo equals that content
and um let's compute that just i don't
know how long it takes no idea
um
okay
so now
all of this junk
okay
so let's talk about this
the
you know okay this table has some more
detail in it but the fact that there's a
header line
you know a header on the top
a thing on the left
in this particular case it has very
specific reasons to have stripes in it
but just even like a header on the left
a header on the right this question
about frame arrow interior would be
the idea of
uh you know there's frame arrow all
you know if i say
grid
you know i'd say table
x
you know
three four or something three five
and now i say
frame arrow all
great okay now i say frame arrow
uh true
okay now what i want to do is let's say
i want the interior frame
okay
that is i want the the console these two
frames right which you actually can't
get using frame you need to use dividers
because which is a little confusing it's
documented but confusing right frame
counts
you know entries whereas dividers counts
the spaces between entries that's fine
but so if i said for example the same
thing
and i said well maybe i'm just being
confused here i mean if i said dividers
arrow all
the that includes everything it's
basically the same as frame equals all
at least in this case right so you'd
need to do this
complicated thing
yeah i mean i think you'd need to do
like
list
uh
false
the li well it's list list
then false
then the list containing true then false
and repeat that as the second entry
right so that's unbelievably obscure yes
right
and so
what i'm trying to do yeah so dividers
go i i i you know maybe we can do this
using frame also i'm not sure
maybe we should have invited lou um
but
yeah i'm not the detail i'm talking
about a framework type thing okay so
there are a couple of different
possibilities i mean one is a grid theme
type thing
which we have talked about and yes i'm a
little bit unconvinced about that
because honestly
i
okay that's one possibility another
possibility which occurs to me
is
a
um is an association
that has things in it where there's a
big long list of things you can you know
imagine there was a giant dialog box of
different things you can do you know
header colors header you know whatever
it is header number of header lines
header color
blah blah blah blah
okay
and
that
what we do is we have two things we have
our existing frame etc etc etc and then
we have which is very structurally
oriented and then we have essentially
functionality oriented
a giant association
let me give an analogy okay in the
cellular automaton function
we have two different ways to specify
the rule
one is by a very compact
kind of
structural method
the other is by saying things like
dimensionality to
you know neighborhood
named neighborhood blah blah
et cetera
this making any sense
so i mean in other words
that in addition to our very compact
i mean
you know
that the real problem is
you know maybe what we need i mean
the problem is that there are categories
of things like the headers what we might
call a header
uh you know alternating rows i don't
know what else there's a we're not bank
describing those things very well
and that's also a nuisance
if you change one of the things that's
happened to me
is you know see all those range three
comma sevens and so on well if i add a
row in here that's all toast
you know everything misaligns and so on
and so on and so on so it'd be better if
i could say i just want the top line the
left hand column
you know to be a particular form and
then i want this and et cetera
can you use negative indices i don't
remember brett maybe you remember i
think you can use
there is a rule form for these specs
which right actually means
right he is using you are using the rule
form which i think does accept negative
specs so you could at least fix some of
those things
and maybe anything that you can't fix is
sufficiently complicated that you
wouldn't
you know design language to handle it it
is yeah but look at how complicated all
that stuff is oh i i totally agree um
i i'm just saying that if you write i
mean it's easy enough to say you know
the first column and the last column
which either we can either we can
already do it using negative indices
or or we should be able to
but you know
if you have enough
enough things that that isn't enough
then
any language we're going to design will
probably not include that and you'll be
stuck doing this well i mean so it's i i
think
you know i'm wondering whether
this could be expanded to take span i
mean that's probably a loot question
we we had we had done something with
span uh
um and i don't i mean because then you
could say two to the end
which is what a lot of the ones in this
are
right
yes in this particular case but i can
imagine
look let's look at the kinds of things
one wants to do once to have a header on
the left or on the top
well i might want to have a summary on
the right like a total or something like
that yes or the bottom yeah right
so in a sense it's the rind of the table
has special things in it that's one case
the other case is that the table is
really a multi-segmented table
it's really a table in table it's it's
three tables
you know all on top of each other with
with more serious separators between the
different pieces possibly with subtotals
right in which case you might actually
want to be using multiple nested grids
rather than one grid with a gazillion
options well except that except that
usually things don't line up properly
then
look i think
our grids
have you know the raw functionality is
just fine the accessibility is awful
you know as this example here
illustrates
so
you know what would make it better
you know and one possibility
that i want to again say
is an association
just has many different things that you
can use to get the same result
and the question of what takes
precedence well that's a detailed
question
but the basic point would be
let's say it says you know
uh
i don't know
um
i mean it just and i think anything that
you came up with would end up being just
as complicated as what you have here
you know it might be slightly
no but differently
packaged but it's differently
complicated because here's what it is
it's just you pick things from a menu
basically and by menu i mean like a menu
at a restaurant rather than a menu in a
software system
right in other words it would say look
let me show you the example of cellular
so so how's that different from a grid
theme
it might not be
might not be except that i in a grid
theme
what i was thinking about more here with
something where there are many
right i mean have you ever looked at the
plot theme page well i mean beyond that
i mean we have data set themes don't we
let's look at a couple of things here
okay so cellular automaton
okay so there's the all these forms here
right
which are
kind of for simple cases they're very
nice for more complicated cases they can
get very complicated
then what we did was we named a bunch of
those cases
okay
and these are very overlapping you know
you if you specified multiple things
here you could over specify things
easily
but they're convenient for common cases
that you want
right let's look at plot beams
right so you have the the main
overarching themes but then you can
customize all sorts of
i know but what we've done here
that the difference here
is that
i mean these are just names of things
they're not settings you don't say
open markers arrow whatever it is
correct just say open markers right
and i mean maybe there's a way of doing
this for grids that will be enough i
don't know
i think the real problem is i think the
real problem is you've got to go in and
say which element gets which thing like
let's say thick lines or something
you don't want the whole
you know making the whole grid with
thick lines is very unlikely to be what
you want you probably want a separator
somewhere inside the grid
right but all right i don't think
i don't think that those would be the
sort of themes we'd want for a grid
right i mean i think we'd want something
like uh
shaded headers uh bolded heads
so look at data set themes
which i mean i think still need work but
i have never used these
i simply have never used these
and that's pathetic under representation
of examples
and
right and so here they do give you the
ability to add some parameters yeah
which is in a horrendously done way in
my opinion
it's just horrendous why why is that
horrendous i mean that's a very common
way to
right you could you could leave it off
or you could uh
i know but it's it's a the thing is that
this is
you know i'd much prefer alternating row
backgrounds to true
or to light blue
than this weird position
what light blue
goes true true as opposed to false
no i understand the alternating row
backgrounds goes to true but then where
does the light blue go
on the right hand side
instead of it being arrow true it's
arrow light blue
um
i see and then so then the next case
would be the list yeah right okay i mean
i would prefer automatic rather than
true in that case automatic versus none
so
oh
i mean it's still
you know gets into the case of
you have to package up that you know in
your example on the left
you have
sort of two columns of headers i mean
one is actually a header and one is
something
different from all the other columns i
know i know it's a fairly complicated
case so i'm i'm not
i mean i'm right
which is getting back to what i was
saying of like you know this particular
table may be such that there is no
reasonably simple language that actually
okay so what i'm what i'm suggesting is
that we do things like
uh
let's say
um
column header format
or something
um
that's not enough right i mean
i will just point out
you know one of my concerns is that
right we already have two different
languages for these options right we
have the original grid box language and
then the somewhat cleaned up language we
created
for grid
and
you know and so
the original grid box language is
absolutely subterranean uh uh
i don't disagree i'm just saying it
exists and i mean i haven't thought
about that in 20 years
and that's a good thing
yeah i i think it's more likely to say
that you haven't thought about it in 16
years since there was a
grid but um whatever
but uh you know um right but you know we
have a translation between those and and
and you know you can create these things
and then you can edit them and the
things are preserved now if we create
yet another language
i mean i don't know that this thing will
be at all editable right so it'll
display beautifully but the moment you
edit it you might lose
everything um
i know this is right i think that needs
a discussion with like lou and john what
happened to the editability of datasets
uh i think that went into hibernation
when chris carlson retired
um
and and
jose is here so he can speak up if i'm
misrepresenting that but
um well we placed it in the x kernel and
then it entered into conflicts with
something else and was removed you
remember that didn't i okay
all right but then
so
but even when it was an external it
wasn't being actively worked on as far
as i know okay can somebody make sure
it's in the global project list
yeah i got that
okay
um
let's see
so
look i'm not giving up here
i mean i think
but by the way i mean i haven't used
what is it called
table view what is it called the the the
typical view
no
what's the thing that's the editable
version of um
[Music]
what the heck
what's wrong with that what the heck
oh don't tell me this is broken come on
guys
okay
come on we can do better than this
do you see what i did
yeah i said all the all x's
yeah i i i oh i know what the right the
issue is you you write that the default
uh
format is is is not expression right i
think that the but that's obviously
wrong
it's obviously wrong this shouldn't do
that with no message
no
it's just crazy
it's a low level control it's not crazy
i mean i mean
if you if you if you do
you know row with invalid arguments it
just sort of sits down i know but this
isn't a low level control this is
intended for people actually doing you
know editing things i mean i was
intending to use it
you know i had something i was going to
keep a bunch of values where i want to
enter things every so often i was going
to use this
so that's just not good enough that it
just does nothing in that case
also i have no idea why the fonts are so
stupid here
okay well there's there's nobody here
who can speak to that
jeremy hill
i'm here yeah i think billy's here i the
fonts are just standard code font
for numbers we didn't choose source sans
which we could have
but we just left it as the standard code
font
i don't think it looks right
i think the arguments
the hundreds of cells are both
the zeros are distinct from the the uh
o's in this case
which might be one argument
source
in this case here
okay so first of all the fact that it
jumps to make a double height you know
multi-height thing in that case just
totally with the thing off center it's
just bonkers
you see that
it's just a stupid bug of some kind
okay
so i mean
i i absolutely do not buy a ties
argument this is intended as a top level
used by users type thing it is not a low
level control
but but it is a control just like you
know
treeview and
all those other connections
and right they don't issue messages they
provide interfaces to the front end
well they're pink
uh
stylistically sometimes but
okay listen this is not right this
should just work
but we don't have the right people in
this meeting to figure out why
so can somebody please take that up with
john fultz
i also just think this font is wrong
you can make it look better but
the benefit is that the zeros and o's
look different you know
zero because we don't have in this
particular case
we in fact as we just learned here we
can't even deal with those
you can't but can you have strings those
are
symbols i think you have pure strings
pure numbers but not
symbols yeah
okay
i mean
they're quoted so that helps but i
didn't think they were quoted by default
yeah yeah do right make the the only
editing is an input form or is it an
input cell
yeah so right so in the in your random
int replace your random integer of 100
with you know the string capital o
okay why is that quoted there
because you explicitly typed it in right
it's already the raw type so
well i think the thing is that it's an
input cell instead of an output cell oh
that might also be the case no it was in
the output cell as well
yeah no
okay fine
i don't know why that happened
i see yeah
okay i mean honestly this looks pretty
good here
this seems useful i mean the the use
case that i have for it
involves entering numbers from like
pieces of paper
okay for which i think this is probably
pretty good
tabs through and so on
yeah it's nice
let's clean it up so people can actually
use it
i mean it does seem to be i don't know
does it have more than three examples
yes it does actually have more than
three examples
oh gosh then we have text grid don't we
which desperately needs more examples
and desperately needs a thing that does
better than just saying has the same
options as grid how many times do i have
to tell people we can't do that
well until the infrastructure is in
place to deal with it i thought
i thought we've worked on the
infrastructure is that not done it's not
done talk to brian i mean until brian
provides us with something this will not
be fixed so that is why they can't
cancel the monthly documentation meeting
for tomorrow
um
so that they need to deal with i mean i
i don't know what's happened to that
me send mail about that well maybe um
uh
avery could perhaps take that message
that that issue has to be fixed has to
be a way to do this because i'm you know
we gotta actually not have this in
another version the same nonsense again
and i gave them a roadmap for how to
build the infrastructure if they don't
agree with it they should tell me
otherwise they should build it
yep
i can pass that along
i think with a little bit of force
because i'm not happy that they tried to
cancel that meeting
um okay can we move on to the next item
because i think it would be more
productive if i had a focused meeting
with you know john and lou and brett and
we about which about this about yes
about the general issue of grid and okay
let me just summarize where i think
we're potentially going with this okay
it is my
feeling not super strong
okay
i don't think
i think themes will only get us so far
because i think that there's an awful
lot that has to be specific to i want
these locations to work this way and
what i think
is that okay so i'm going to make a
claim
okay my claim is going to be that there
are named positions in a grid
and that if we had something where just
like we can right now have position
three seven goes to whatever
i might be wrong about this i mean maybe
maybe what we want to be able to say
maybe we can already do this is to say
one blank goes to whatever
or
maybe the alternative to that is headers
or row headers or something column
headers goes to whatever
so what i'm suggesting is that we simply
okay claim might not be right
that the major problem is that we need
addressable we need named locations in
the grid
see what i'm saying
and again i don't know if one blank
actually works i mean let's try that and
if i say grid
uh you know this thing here
and i say
you know background
arrow and then i say
let's just do a very raw thing
which you know one blank
arrow red
splattereroo
see if that works try one minus one that
that i think
would be i mean that would certainly
help with a fair
well i think there's another possibility
which is that has to be this
no
there's a lot of different
ways of adding lists around this thing
that i might try but
yeah but you see that this is we're
losing the game here i mean
you see what i'm saying if we could have
a way
to let's imagine that so so i think
one possibility
right but could you try
a way of specifying
named
types of things
yeah so the you know this span of
positions
is a header position yeah i know that's
what i'm suggesting yeah and and then
we leverage what we have in the data set
themes
which
are designed around
you know doing things with headers doing
things
yeah yeah yeah
look i mean if if we could say
background error arrow
you know
headers
arrow light grey
that would already be helpful
or even
alternating
rows
arrow green whatever it is
you know what i'm saying
well i think i i mean if we did this i
think we'd probably want that to be an
association just so it's
clearly distinct from all these good
ideas that's a good idea no i think
that's a good idea
i think it's a good idea
and i mean
you know we could do that and we could
even have an association where if you
want
the thing look that's probably the
solution but it's just an association
with named locations and if you do have
a specific
uh you know if you do have a specific
cell one one arrow whatever fine just
put it in there
right but you have a bunch of named ones
mm-hmm
and i mean how would that work
let's say frame arrow
you know interior arrow true i don't
know whether that's the right way to do
it well again i think this this needs to
be divided it's just because of the i
think i think
but
i mean there's you know if you're
revisiting this in modern
times
i mean you could have things like
dividers goes to
place of string
headers comma below or something
oh that's an interesting idea yeah we
have
you know a lot more descriptive types of
things these days than we did
back in v6 era
yeah
i tend to think that there are things
that we would really love to do with
like call outs on a table which is a
quite separate issue
i think it'll be wonderful if we could
do that
drop shadows in parts of a table things
like
this um
yeah sandra is commenting about large
and long tables being able to freeze
headers yeah but i mean that that's in
the general category of i mean that's
much more like table view
or data set
there hasn't been a thing we've been
providing for grid so that's a separate
issue but i i think
i think look i think the first thing we
should look at is
i am pushing for
right now
named
locations
to which these things apply
i don't think that the the you know
background and things like that i don't
think those are that bad i don't think
that there's anything wrong with those i
mean we're mostly talking about
oh god that annoys me so much this
doesn't have its options here
gosh that annoys me
you know frame frame style i get all
those things they they're okay
um
although we could have an association
for
frame we could allow something which has
a um uh
um
yeah
ethan has commented on the test case
should be to replicate tables and
academic papers which are super hard to
do
in our system and in pretty much any
other system i mean they're ones where
you literally you go in and you
basically just give typesetting
primitives
rope the problem is that we have
automatically generated tables and those
are much harder to do than the ones that
you could put in and you know tech or
something by hand where it's five rows
right there's a vastly easier problem
than what we have here
but
um
you know look i i i think we should
figure out how to do this with names i
think that the good news is
that
like like if you look at these things
even you know any one of these things
spacings
like
yeah it's just totally obscure
horizontal spacing vertical spacing just
you know spacings arrow horizontal arrow
blah whatever arrow blah
etc and i mean sometimes
i think we should start with this
start with trying to do this
does that seem reasonable to people
you think so
okay sorry i was muted i i will you know
like i said i'm not going to actually
agree to anything without talking to
john and lou first but look at this look
at what i just saw here look at what i
just saw here
now would anybody ever have figured this
out look at this i'm going to show you
something amazing
uh wait a minute common settings for
frame include center
and it's pink
that's not what it says it should do
yeah
that's interesting
[Music]
um
looks like it got translated badly into
something
okay well it doesn't even have an
example does it
okay well so that's a bug so someone
needs to look at that
i got it
future dividers goes to center just
for kicks
wonder if there was a doc's error
i don't know
but either way it should get fixed
okay anyway we've got things to do with
grid and we have some kind of road map
of where to go next with this
and the first thing is kind of trying
out
named positions for things
and see how that works they're an
association format for the right-hand
side of existing options
seems reasonable to people
i mean look this is just painfully
obscure
[Music]
don't think anybody's going to disagree
with you about that
wow look at that syntax that's wild i
was gonna say the only thing worse than
writing those is parsing them
well okay fair enough
okay oh yes the rectangle syntax i
forgot about i forgot i knew about this
one but i forgot about it i completely
forgot about this i completely forgot i
mean that's an amusing thing i would
have been able to use that a bunch of
times
here's another question
how much should we push for a gui
or is a gui going to be horrible too
i'm not sure
i mean
i think that's a question for john
i mean okay
although there is the options uh
it's not called the
option
navigator
what is that thing that kevin has worked
on
option inspector
no no no not the option inspector there
it was this thing to sort of dynamically
uh i mean there has been some work on
this um i don't think it's any build uh
in any build but
brad do you know what i'm talking about
uh
i vaguely remember it and i don't
remember what it was called okay anyway
um so so there has been some work on
un-gui for such things and you know we
like i said these are questions for john
okay all right okay
let's move on then
ethan do you need me for the information
stuff
uh i
not
okay then i'm gonna
take off so okay see you bye
okay what are we looking at here
so
um i mean i can tell you things are ugly
like that that font is just way way way
too big there
um
well you complained i guess about the
header
last week so and i was like well i'm
also going to tell you that this font is
way too big i don't know how it ends up
being so big well it's the well that's
the problem of forcing fonts into
objects right so you have
you know we decreed some font size for
date object so now it's using that font
size it shouldn't be using the size it
should be using the style but not the
size inherited size maybe at best
well yes but that's that's not how
right that's not how uh design typically
specs them these typically give us a
spec in some number of points and most
people who are not me will just
use that okay so that's wrong so we need
to go chase that one okay so okay
that's that's that now these headers
okay i don't think these headers are
right and my reason for saying that is
it's sort of a detailed piece of
metadata what this is because most of
the time it's totally obvious you know
what it is
so the fact that this feels like it's
the most
you know
is it correct does billy think that's i
i was in the meetings when we designed
these i thought they were tiny
like really tiny
but
it's been a while
yeah i'm not uh it's it's been a while
i'm not sure i think they were used to
be a little bit smaller though
so maybe it's just a bug
so who who built them as they are right
now
that'd be me i mean they they were to
spec we had started with tiny ones they
were hard to see we increased the size
somewhat but made it smaller than the
sub
heading
[Music]
we could certainly play around with
making it okay i think it's wrong okay
so and it might help if it was in
italics possibly i'm not sure
it needs to make it clear that it's
metadata
we want to de-emphasize it and make sure
yeah i mean you know i i it just seems
wrong so it's this is a detailed design
thing i don't think there's any more to
say about this i mean billy could mock
it up right here just make it a bit
smaller
i you know
this seems straightforward just a small
small glitch right um right and but we
also have ones which don't have the
subheading which i don't know how that
fits into that but
what's an example well those four right
in front of you
that's okay i mean if it's smaller it's
okay
well i think it's that that's the same
size as the ones you were complaining
about
no i know but i'm saying if you make
this smaller oh i seem to be okay i
think roughly if the font size is
matched there right if it's roughly the
same font size as color space it's
we're in the right ballpark i would
think so
okay
yeah
all right so like
as it says this is a sort of mostly an
fyi uh partly because it evolved since
you saw it and partly because some of
what you were told
was uh wrong so um
i i i recall that we use
sort of bluish things for data driven
icons and gray for
generic icons wow i didn't know that i
mean i could have guessed but i didn't
know that
okay
well it's what we've been doing since v9
um wow
okay
so
um
right and so
you know porters etc they're exactly
what jeremy right so jeremy
jeremy did review this and and you know
i i took the exact rgb setting he gave
me and and put it in
all those things
um so what are we discussing here right
so you didn't like the
icons for the new structured matrices
they have been improved
um
or at least some of them have been
improved
um and the others are using i will point
out are using exactly what we've been
doing what did i not like i mean which
side the left or the right
the left
i don't have a big problem with these i
mean what i'm concerned about now
is the thing that our node has been
chasing which is some insanities about
the fact that it takes you know .01
seconds to do something and then 10
seconds to typeset it because it's
trying to draw this beautiful picture
that nobody's even going to see
uh
well
i i
have not been called into that
bug report if if it is then that's about
that should be fixed i mean the the time
limit uh i mean the time limit i use for
most of these things is like
it's a second or less i don't remember
exactly
how long it is it should be much less
than that because i'll tell you why the
place where i've been toasted on this
is i've got a table of 100 of these
things
see it's horrifying
uh i don't think it's that common to
produce a hundred in a single
well it's common to produce
other kind it is common to produce
this is something we didn't think of
okay
we thought this is going to be one
produced per output line and it isn't
there are plenty of places where you
produce many of them right but
i mean right i mean
it can't be less than say a tenth of a
second or the visualization functions
just won't finish in time no matter how
many i mean
what we should do we can't make it for a
size a million matrix there is no way we
can make something that will you know
draw it in reasonable time
and
actually i think uh size a million
matrix we actually can handle all right
okay fine but not but but yes we do we
also do have size limits so certainly
above i'm pretty sure above a million
and with like permutation matrix you go
up above 30 by 30
and it'll it'll use the generic icon
because
right it only stores the permutation so
actually just generating
the
yeah
okay so
my point is i think
look if we had to go to generic icons
only i think
unless it's really tiny i think that
would not be a crime
okay i think that it is much worse to
have any possibility that there's
significant type setting time
and i think that down sampling or random
sampling to get some idea of what the
thing looks like would be just fine
are you are you suggesting that i am so
incredibly stupid that i'm not down
sampling
no i'm not suggesting that actually
i have no idea
because because because you know they're
that right all these
you know in matrix plots they're all
limited to 30 by 30
points so you down sample before you
plot yes
or or i rely on matrix plot you know for
things that i know matrix plot will do a
good job itself
i just trust example
yeah
i didn't know it did that i think it
down samples at much higher values i
mean i think you'd have to parameterize
the down something because you're going
for 30 by 30 a matrix plot has never
seen a plot that small
oh
it
it it it has i forget the name of the
option but you can tell it
don't produce more than 30 by 30 points
love
it and it's it and it's pretty darn fast
max plot points max plot points
okay
sander is commenting that for polygon
this is really bad uh
i know that's not your area yeah yes
okay
to take that
because i mean this is something our
node is supposed to be dealing with just
go look at all of these and make sure
that none of them are slow
i don't have evidence that your ones by
the way attire is slow
okay i just have evidence that there are
summary blobs that are slow i think
polygon it's type setting not rendering
right it's not generating the image but
it's type setting this weird blob i've
run into that too and a lot of times you
can get huge lists of polygons
i don't understand what we're talking
about here because the fact is the issue
is
you know if i say how do i get a lot of
polygons i just say random polygon
um
okay so i make a table of of um
oh for god's freaking sake look at this
i mean
that wasn't that was just stupid i mean
it was like i'm sure that the actual
computation time there
is blindingly oops
yeah it'll be milliseconds
yep
right no no no no no no well okay so now
there are there are two potential issues
one is right so you could time how much
two boxes on that takes
um and then there's also how long it
takes to render in the front end
and and there is some issue and i don't
remember the details but
um yeah if you do the input and do slash
two boxes i'm curious and you know
absolute timing of it
that would be interesting which which so
so take this table uh and just do two
boxes of it semicolon and see how long
that takes
ops what am i doing
so not super fast but not terrible right
that's
uh
go to two or three hundred though for
quantity
right and i think
i think part of this is that uh
i it takes a way a lot longer to run to
typeset it right in 1.5
yeah and i think
uh
right so part of the slowness is
definitely rendering in the front end
and i think it's that there's a bunch of
dynamics in there to tell you
right when you open it up all these
dynamics yeah i know so there's
something stupid about that if i might
say so i mean right yeah but
i i i will just say that charles did
something pretty custom there these
aren't exactly normal summary boxes
although i've run into things like this
with huge lists of dates and hughes
lists of geo positions
that was 2.5 seconds i couldn't do my
stopwatch
you get into like a thousand i've done
it with you know
put a thousand there
yeah i know i know we can get it to fail
right
um and it's all front end so you could
two box that and it won't take that long
to correct so so listen this is a speed
chase
so to speak
we
are trying to develop a methodology for
doing these is just another one to do
right and we
i mean we sped up some right there was
something with like
nine patch versus
something else background and and that
we did some speed up for 1301
um but yeah i don't know that we fully
understand what all of the speed issues
are with polygon
right well i'm not sure it's specific to
polygon i think it's summary boxes in
general and
and particularly ones that have some
kind of dynamic content in them
right
okay
anything else we need to cover right now
today
don't think so
great
thanks all